my god you've done it again do you
realize that you have clicked on my face
once again thus justifying this video's
existence and i thank you for that and
while this video is brought to you by
athletic greens i will talk about that
later in the video but first if that
uncharted movie left a bad taste in your
mouth
this is an alternative
[Music]
so the lost city is one of those make
your way through the tropical forest in
the middle of nowhere trying to avoid
the bad guys but hopefully find the lost
city type adventure movie stars channing
tatum and sandra bullock and at first i
was like this actually
it feels unique not like the movie
always sticks to landing and keeps that
feeling of feeling unique but i thought
the setup was really good sandra bullock
plays this author who essentially writes
smut novels but with an archaeological
twist she's educated in archaeology by
trade that's where her heart lies but
she kind of fell into writing these
romance novels but it's not fulfilling
for her for her new book she's not
inspired to write it channing tatum
plays the model on the covers of her
books you know the model the fabio
character you know the fabio the blonde
hair is dipping right he plays that
character he plays fabio but he's not
fabio
you remember fabio
a lot of my young audience lou the [ __ ]
is that their parents are like yeah
right don't believe a small bottle then
daniel radcliffe plays this really rich
eccentric guy who's convinced that
sandra bullock is the only one who can
lead him to this lost city of d
they make a lot of jokes about the name
so he's looking for the lost city of
dick he's kidnapped her channing tatum
goes and tries to rescue her though he's
completely unqualified to do so so
channing tatum and sandra bullock are
trying to cluster [ __ ] their way through
this forest and baddies are chasing them
and
archaeology adventure movie now when
this movie works it does work and it
works because of the chemistry between
sandra bullock and channing tatum
channing tatum continues to impress me
with his comedic timing i mean at first
i was like yeah the guy from step up who
cares i think it was step up otherwise
known as channing tatum movies i never
watched but i worked at the theater and
i think i remember that correctly step
up
also a lot of trash the point is
around the time of 21 jump street 2012
thereabouts i was like channing tatum
has really good comedic timing i'm glad
he's getting that recognition because i
never gave him that recognition not
until then anyway and in this movie he
really shows it once again and although
i was impressed with the chemistry
between the two when the movie starts
getting too romantic i don't buy it at
all i mean at best optimistically for
the future of the two of these
characters i imagine she would find him
infatuating and then at the end when
they're back on land and they're away
like she's not gonna call him
she's not i just don't buy that kind of
connection between the two past an
infatuation in this situation at this
moment i mean they're going to find a
place called the lost city of d
now's the time just saying
ever there was a time but when the two
are bantering back and forth and they're
dealing with the problem at hand i
actually i liked the two of them very
much daniel radcliffe wasn't on screen
as much it's kind of why i compare this
to uncharted he when he's on screen
he absolutely it's his scene and when
he's not you're just dealing with the
heroes at hand makes him a proper
uncharted villain but i really did buy
him as this young rich guy who has
something to prove because his brother
essentially was given the company and
he's like no no i'm worth more and i'll
prove it i'll find this priceless thing
the movie's not as action-fueled as it
is them trying to squirrel themselves
away from danger maybe using a couple of
booby traps when time calls for it well
correction before they're doing that
there is a character that's on screen
that's actually a surprise cameo that i
loved i love this surprise cameo but i'm
like it's it's channing tatum sandra
bullock
he's not gonna be there the entire time
and he's not but when he is there the
movie is super action-packed and it's
actually never as badass as it is when
he is on screen however there are
characters in this movie that suffer
from a severe
lack of awareness just
aware of their surroundings aware of the
people that are
clearly in their field of view when
making a movie like this you got to
think like what would metal gear solid
do if you would be seen in a metal gear
solid game you just you can't walk that
path that's line of sight you can't do
it example there's a scene where they
see someone coming like oh we gotta hide
no we can't hide we have to scale the
cliff which would clearly make us
visible to him also you're wearing a
very bright pink glittery outfit so
you're definitely going to stand out
regardless the scene cuts to where
they're almost at the top of this
precipice that they're climbing doesn't
show how they got there without the guys
seeing them there are moments like that
in this movie where i'm like that
doesn't make any logistical sense a lot
of the comedic reaction lines are given
when it's a reaction shot of them
walking away and you just hear the audio
you can't see their mouths moving it
just feels like it was a reaction shot
of them leaving and then after the first
cut of the movie they watched it and
they were like oh we could use reaction
line there
in there
in there
and there we can just add audio that's
easy just don't show their mouths it
does feel slightly out of place some of
the things said were funny though some i
was like oh it's the best you got okay
fair but in the end by the end the
movie's quirky unbelievable to a lot of
degrees but to its core there is an era
of fun to it that i did have i thought
this movie is going to be a bus fire i
surprisingly had a fun time with it no
alcohol required and as mentioned
earlier in this video this video is
brought to you by athletic greens ag-1
by athletic greens is a daily supplement
that has become part of my daily health
routine it has 75 different ingredients
including vitamins minerals superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens which helps
with stress and let's face it in this
stress field world i will take all the
help i can get plus ag-1 helps in that
post-workout recovery and i am currently
down 10 pounds 10 pounds of pure garbage
ouch i feel like i'm on the right track
but i personally love the simplicity of
it one scoop to eight ounces of water
shake done but as for my routine put it
in a blender add a banana some ice blend
bangarang so click the link below or go
to
athleticgreens.com and they'll give you
my glorious people a special offer of
vitamin d plus five travel packs for
those who subscribe to ag1 thank you
once again to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
alright so the lost city have you seen
it what did you think about it what did
you prefer velocity or uncharted it
really hinges on whether or not you've
seen two movies which
maybe that's a tall order no no but
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you